since you used since you brought in
Europeans I do think this it's an
important that particularly this
audience and I'm sure agrees to point
out that Donald Trump is not an American
phenomenon solely an American phenomenon
we see we see Trump's emerging all
across the West all across all across
Europe Western Europe and Eastern Europe
and they are repeating themselves in
very similar ways I think this is
related to the cultural thing that you
won't let me talk about can I say it
okay okay there are three points to make
about culture all right number one is to
do with pop culture people have talked a
little bit about Reagan and Reaganism I
recently read a book about Reagan that
reminded me the degree to which Reagan
was the embodiment of the popular
culture of his time he was a Hollywood
actor he he he believed in the values of
Hollywood which were by the way the
values of film companies all across
Europe and around the world and the
values of Hollywood were good guys win
good good triumphs over evil the nice
guy gets the girl you know and he
embodied those and those were those were
the kinds of things you can laugh at it
and people did but those were the things
that people looked up to and admired
what does Trump embody he embodies the
values of reality television reality
television is something we have in the
Netherlands we have it in France we have
it in America we have it in Britain what
is who wins in reality television the
most vulgar the loudest the printer who
doesn't get voted off the island it's
often the person who who shoves the
other people aside and this is the most
popular form of entertainment in the
West right now and he is he comes from
it he was of it he embodies it he he
reflects its values people understand
what he's doing the most brilliant
analysis of Trump I've seen was somebody
who analyzed him by comparing him to the
victors of reality television series he
is he is literally doing what they do in
order to win the contest that that's
what he is that's how that's how you win
the second point is to do with the
nature of the Internet and the nature of
political information now which is the
same now exactly the same in the United
States and Europe and we spoke about
this a good deal last night the the the
Internet has changed the way in which
people receive news people don't receive
news from newspapers directly or from
television directly although to some
degree they still do they receive it
from their friends and from their social
networks which means that it's curated
and separated in a way that it never
used to be and this has a number of
effects one of them there was a very
brilliant thing that the Wall Street
Journal did a couple of days ago which
is it put up on one page a liberal
Facebook feed and a conservative
Facebook feed and you can you can I
highly recommend you look at it you can
press on a button and see what the
conservatives are saying right now about
I dunno Hillary Clinton or terrorism and
what the Liberals are saying and they
are completely different worlds they
live in completely different universes
and part of what's underlying the
problem that the governor described of
people not being able to talk to each
other is that we now have political
systems and this is I live part of the
time in London and part of the time in
Poland I mean this is underlying the
growing gap between the parties and the
reason why people can't have a shared
conversation is because they don't they
literally don't have the same facts
anymore they're not there they don't see
that this they don't see the same
reality and I promise you that's true in
Poland I proud and that it's to some
degree true here people simply don't see
the same numbers the same I'm watching
right now the British the brexit
campaign there is one number that that
the out campaign can keep citing which
is that Britain pays 350 million pounds
a week to to Europe this is a fictitious
number it has been proved over and over
again that this is wrong this is not the
real number you can play their numbers
you can come up with it doesn't reflect
anything it's not a number that you will
immediately get back from Europe and
you'll be able to spend it on the
National Health Service it's fake
nevertheless they use it they put it on
the side of their campaign buses they
put it on posters they use it over and
over again it does not matter how many
times it's debunked or how many
fact-checking web sites take it apart
this is
simply not part this you can't do that
anymore the debate so you now have
completely separate worlds and that how
do you even have democracy and this is
not an American problem this is a
problem of the West how do you have
democracy now if the democratic nations
aren't talking about the same thing and
don't agree on what's happening they
don't you can't analyze you can't solve
a problem if you don't agree on what it
is and so you know the statistics about
terrorism is just about about
immigration they are completely
different depending on which form of
media you're reading and that makes a
rational and sensible debate impossible
that's why you have so many so many
everything like we you know we know in
this country you know in France we know
in Poland we know in Hungary there are
so many of you know examples now of
politicians who are able to to operate
on completely phony views of reality and
sell them to people because because they
can see it on the Internet the second
effect I mean they're there multiple but
the second effect is it the onslaught
and cascade of information that people
now have in democracies devalues the
political process you know ruins the
undermines that's the word I want
undermines political speech I mean you
can have you read so much there's so
much information there's so much news
some of its true some of its false can
you really believe any of it or any of
these people up there really telling you
the truth aren't all those guys lying
which who do you believe who's who's
who's authentic you know maybe Trump is
authentic cuz he shouts louder you know
maybe Bernie Sanders is authentic
because he you know he because he wants
to he wants to attack Russia people cuz
he's old you know he's not he's not
media friendly no I'm serious he he
looks not he's not a made up politician
you know so he looks like an authentic
person Jeremy Corbyn leaves the Labour
Party in Britain for similar reasons
he's authentic he's real you know
never mind that his his views are
irrational and he's advocating policies
that didn't work the last thing they
were tried thirty years ago you know but
but because he seems authentic in in an
era when there's so much garbage around
he he has an appeal so we're operating
we're not operating in the same
political culture even of five years ago
you know five years ago the political
world was different people were getting
their information in different ways so
what's the there's a reason why these
different Trump's and these different
real Wilders is and these different
coaching skis you know are emerging all
over democratic countries all at once
and it's because of the nature the way
in which people get political
information and the disappearance of the
real world and real facts from politics
it seems to me that Trump has combined
because Trump is a reality television
guy he gets to change his facts whenever
he wants to he can say something at 10
a.m. and at 2 p.m. he says exactly the
opposite he's done it so fine I tell you
in on reality has been exactly facts are
obliterated in this it's not just that
we have different facts facts are
obliterated they have no meaning anymore
more than that when Donald Trump is
asked where he got his information he
says I got it on the Internet
this is not entirely new I mean I've
been involved in lots of campaigns and
I've always tried to tell my liberal
college professor friends campaigns are
not educational Affairs they it is not
about facts
it is about emotion about narrative
about story and I think we have to I
mean everything Ann said is true I think
but there's a little more piece to the
Trump story he has a narrative that
explains the world I argue this is the
first actual election about
globalization because there's a lot
going on in the world okay and Trump
puts it all into a neat story you know
he's got the bad guys the Mexicans and
the Muslims and the Chinese they're the
bad guys and he's got really clear easy
solutions build the wall build the
tariffs and will make America great
it is a believable story if you don't
spend a lot of time on you know reading
books or being college professor and
you're pissed off plus he tells you we
can't be bought so that's probably why
his story is true and Bernie has a
similar story Bernie doesn't get into
details birdie doesn't bother with fad
you seem bothered with human beings it's
Wall Street you know break him up free
this you know it's the system political
revolution Bernie's been saying this for
you know years well but no Matt Lisa
actually tries to have some facts but I
mean the point is that Bernie has a
story he has a narrative line and it
appeals to his supporters just like
Trump does and you know narrative is
very powerful in politics emotion
emotional resonance count there and and
where criticisms of the narrative would
get through it well they don't if you
live in the in the conservative half of
the or the far-right whatever you're
going to call it a piece of the facebook
world you don't get anything that
contradicts that narrative you don't
ever see it it doesn't penetrate that's
all true but I just don't want to deny
the power of both candidates and the
fact that look the globalized world is
pretty scary to a lot of people and I
think that we can a fault whatever there
is of a global elite whether they're
liberal or conservative who said you
know this is the great era
everything's fine everybody's gonna get
better we have this wonderful globalized
world and somehow nationalism would go
away no there are people who don't like
this world that's what the real revolt
is of Isis and other groups they are
opposed to this globalized world and you
know we haven't taken that I think
seriously enough it's a much more
complicated issue than just you know
people are misusing facts or it's the
Internet I think is largely neutral here
I mean I agree with Ann and Derek and
other people I mean you know I actually
it's gonna get worse I think pretty soon
you're gonna have their eyeglasses
you're gonna have intravenous things and
you're gonna pick whether Facebook or
Google provides you with your
information and it's gonna be inserted
into your nervous system right I mean
it's gonna be a little Network moving
about that cuz it's gonna be you know I
mean you're you know but on the other
side we have more resources to check
facts now and than we've ever had all
you have well well okay
oh I happen to agree with you but that
the point is you have the resources
there so the question is why are they
not believing them why aren't they going
to them and what I want to suggest and
it's not this probably will not be
popular around here but who knows um is
that the real issue here is that we have
had an experiment that's been going on
depending on how you look at it either
since the 1930s of the 1960s in either
case it's with a time when college
professors and college educated people
entered politics in a massive way and
college education became a dominant
requirement of politics and the people
who are college educated what hunter
Arendt calls problem solvers have asked
for a bargain let us do it and we'll
solve the problems and over the last 70
years they failed the problems haven't
gotten better and I think the well I
don't think education has gotten better
I don't think immigrations gotten better
that's just not a truth well I okay well
I okay you ever look at metrics do i we
have metrics yes poverty is puppies
cured we have the best higher education
we have best universities in the entire
world yes in what sense
best quality of research best quality
professors best students you mean wrong
professors spend no time teaching it's
not and largely spend their time do you
live in I mean on University I mean